two small business owners i met
on the road in the last couple weeks and
uh the first was a
very entrepreneurial woman named
pilar savala
and um she's from florida miami
and tam mikenger uh who is in wisconsin
they have different businesses and uh
live in different places
but both share the same message with me
when i spoke to them on the road
and that was american small businesses
are hurting hurting badly
and they need help now and it's in all
of our interest to make sure they get
the help now
small businesses are the engines of our
economic
progress they're the glue in the heart
and soul of our communities
but they're getting crushed since the
beginning of this pandemic
400 thousand small businesses have
closed four hundred thousand
and millions more are hanging by a
thread
it's hurting black latino and asian
american communities the hardest
walk down any main street and you see it
empty storefronts goodbye signs hanging
in the windows
maybe it's the pizza place you used to
take your family to dinner
or the hardware store that always had
the tool you needed
it's the mom mom-and-pop shop that's
that's sponsored by
uh that is supported by the community
and then in turn they support the
community
they sponsor the little league team the
barber shop with the first dollar bill
that he or she earned still taped to the
wall
along with a picture of their kids who
are now in college
these small businesses not the ones with
500
employees but these small businesses
that with a handful of folks they are 90
of the businesses in america but when
the paycheck protection
program was passed a lot of these
mom-and-pop businesses got muscled out
of the way
by bigger companies who jumped in front
of the line
i want to be clear the paycheck
protection program is a bipartisan
effort
democrats and republicans help pass it
but democrats and republicans have also
voiced concerns
about improving it their input
that's what we're doing in our
administration improving it
in the last month we've increased the
share of funding
for small businesses with fewer than 10
employees
by nearly 60 percent for businesses in
rural communities
the share of funding is up nearly 30
percent since we came to office
and the share of funding distributed
through banks
that traditionally help minority-owned
businesses
is up more than 40 and today
i'm announcing additional changes to the
ppp
program that will make sure we look out
for the mom-and-pop
business even more than we already have
as i explained to pilar and tim the two
small business people i spoke to
on wednesday the small business
administration is going to establish
a 14-day exclusive ppp
loan application period for businesses
and nonprofits
with fewer than 20 employees
people can can go out and find
how to get hold of these these loans
people can find out more at the sba.gov
small business administration will also
remove barriers
that have stopped many businesses from
being able to apply for these loans
for example we're making it so that a
student loan default
or a non-fraud related criminal record
does not prohibit someone from applying
for the program
we're also making it easy for those
one-person businesses
like the home repair contractors
beauticians
small independent retailers to secure
forgivable
ppp loans
at the same time we're increasing access
by increasing oversight i invite any
inspector general in this program with
jurisdiction over this program
to closely look at these loans and
report
publicly report on any issues they
uncover
inconsistent with what i'm saying today
we will ensure
every dollar is spent well these changes
will bring much needed long overdue to
help
to small businesses who really need help
staying open
maintaining jobs and making ends meet
and this is a starting point not the
ending point
we need congress to pass my american
rescue plan
it deals with the immediate crisis
facing our small businesses
now critics say the plan is too big let
me ask the rhetorical question
what would you have me cut what would
you leave out
the american rescue plan targets 50
billion dollars
just apart to support the hardest hit
small
businesses after this program expires
the end of march
would you not help invest in them just
let them continue to go under
did you leave them out again like the
previous administration did
one of the things i've heard again and
again from small business owners like
pilar and tim
is that knowing about support is one
thing
being gaining access to getting is
another
that's why we proposed 175 million
dollars to bring community organizations
in to serve as navigators will help them
through this process of application we
will also establish a hotline
with help available in multiple
languages so folks can pick up a phone
and get the help they need to stay open
and serve their community
again the critics is too big should we
just not should we stop spending money
on them
do we not want to return on the
investment that we make in these
businesses to be able to stay open and
thrive and pay back
why would we not want to make sure small
businesses who lack
teams of lawyers bankers and accountants
have an advocate
someone they can rely on to direct them
to help that's there for them
now will be there for them the american
rescue plan
is a rescue plan for america's small
businesses and america's mainstream
businesses
and we need congress to pass it right
away
i'm grateful to the scent in the house
for moving so quickly
and i want to make it clear i'm prepared
to hear ideas about how to make the
american rescue plan
better and cheaper but we have to make
clear who we're helping and who it would
hurt
i always try to help people like tim and
pilar and all the country's small
businesses and families the workers the
communities that depend on them to
survive
recover and grow and it's my hope
my hope that as democrats and
republicans who have backed the ppp
program
that democrats and republicans will back
the american rescue plan
the vast majority of the american people
more than 70 percent
of the american people including a
majority of republicans
want us to act based on all the polling
data act big and act quickly
major economists left right and center
here and abroad
say we should focus on smart investments
that can make
jobs available and and focus on the jobs
and then the people prevent laws to
prevent long-term economic damage
to our nation and to strengthen the
economic competitiveness going forward
in fact an analysis by wall street's
firm
moody's estimates that if we pass my
american rescue plan
the economy will create 7 million
jobs this year this year
we've also been in constant contact with
the mayors
and governors county officials members
of congress of both parties
in every state that includes a letter i
might add for more than 400 mayors
from big and small cities democrat and
republican they agree
we have to act and act now they
understand we're not going to get our
economy back in shape
the millions of people back to work
until we beat this virus
getting our economy back means bringing
our small businesses back
and that's what we're going to do that's
what i'm doing today
we're going to focus the program ends at
the end of march but for the next two
weeks
the only folks who can apply for that
bpp money
are businesses with fewer than 20
employees thank you very much
you